welcome everyone today we're here to
talk about setting sail and the Google
cloud it's streamlined retail operations
my name is Alok parikh and I'm one of
the founders of string and I run part of
the engineering and also today I have
with me
Emile cinta and as you guys know
organizations today can better
understand their customers and also
optimize their operations by making
data-driven decisions and a key
requirement here is to enable real-time
data pipelines in hybrid cloud
environments for both operations and
analytics so I'm gonna call on Neil
today to talk about Macy's journey for
back home organization and how they were
able to set sail in the Google cloud
with stream as the integration partner
so Neil over to you thank you a lot
yeah hi all my name is Neil chintha I
work for Macy's message technology in
the database group so here are mostly so
today we're going to talk about so now
the Macy's use cases how to do a
platform organization and then how the
stream helped us to modernize our
platforms and one of our key initiative
is common services and a bunch of common
services we just initiated and then
inventory pricing and catalog and I'm
going to talk about each of these topics
in our mix lag so here Macy's use case
so I'm taking it as an inventory is our
use case so this is very high level
diagram so what I'm showing here is how
severe is our data
so what stream does for us so then how
are we love raising it so if we talk on
the main points so here our goal is to
streamline orders and inventory
management for customer experience and
also profitability of course so how the
main goal of this use case is to allow
the cloud
and also new business apps and achieve
the real-time visibility so you into the
inventory data and also prevent any out
of stock or invented services so
especially during peak holidays like
Black Friday and Cyber Monday so if you
see on the right side so this is our
high level so so on the left hand side
you see the unprimed data which is
coming from mainframe on some other data
sources so that data will replicate
using stream to the Google so here we
are using a Google storage and cloud
pub/sub so what we are using in the
Google and then we are I'm going to
explain in detail in the next slides so
what are our drivers and benefits here
what drives us to do this we need a
single source of truth across multiple
delights so what is single source of
truth so because we have many databases
like any other shop we have db2 running
and mainframe and Oracle running in
different location and then which
database and each each type has its own
data I am really missing the source so
so this there's one of the major drive
to go for the string and also so the
second one is to reduce the mainframe
maintenance and licenses cuz of course
so there's operational cost of the
mainframe and speed the market impacted
data so residing in multiple different
systems so what does that mean is we
have data I deciding in multiple
databases and then if you need to fast
develop the application so you need to
reach out to the different applications
and the different areas to develop your
application now we are making everything
into single source and then everything
is available in the Google Cloud and
also we want to make sure the different
customer experience across different
systems because we don't want a customer
field in the online customer feeds the
different in the store so that's the
that's main water of omni-channel all
the customer face the same experience
and the finally but at last so so this
is the inability to sunset an existing
legacy systems so some of the legacy
systems if you need to sunset
so we need to might get the data to some
other place that cloud so so this stream
is helping us so this is our
architectural diagram say it's still
very high level so here I'm going to
take a little longer time to explain
what we are doing and so what we can
expect from here so if you see on the
left side of the diagram that is our
Macy's on from data centers wait the
data exists so so we have inventory data
is exist in the mainframe db2 so db2 on
mainframe
so NASA Oracle databases so that data is
a replicating using stream to the GCP
cloud so that is a called spanner and as
a thumbs up
so what swim does here right so stream
so once an app so that will read the
source data so so stream map contains
multiple tables one or many tables which
contains series the source data and not
play at the target so you can so you can
so you can capture and apply so you can
collects tracked and push so that's what
stream is doing right now so if you
focus on the middle part of the string
so they so we're calling as a VM and so
if suppose V M 1 will be M 2 so but
those two so we are running two VMs in
the GCP so so we are running two VMs
because so search the high availability
purpose so if an app runs in these VMs
and one VM goes down for any reason for
the maintenance of anything apps
automatically fail Yahoo to other PM
seamlessly and then we do not see any
impact there is no business impact and
so the reason I would recommend at least
to Williams for the same cluster to
minimize any outages so supercell is
running in GM
so in the TCP VMs and then that data is
push it over to the spanner and also
thumbs up and also it came to the BQ so
but I've learned is upstream is so it
can apply all three are out too at the
same time so you don't need to depend on
each other so now how are we doing is so
so swim saw unarmed tram we're all
running a golden gate so Oracle
GoldenGate so the Golden Gate trying
fire so stream has ability to read the
Golden Gate trial files and then convert
into interpretation of the targets I so
so that's a long thing so and then if
you see those options like online
migration faces so there we mentioned
two steps when it is in shallower
another one is a large face at CDC what
is you should know so when I create a
new table at the target location in the
cloud spanner
so the table is empty so we take the
social data so it's like a flock fire so
in this stream app can read a flat file
and then it up play like all the inserts
into the driver side so let's say so if
they do at the time t1 so I took the
flat file from the source and then I
apply all the data into the target after
two hours time to time t1 plus 2 or
since 92 so so time t2 or both source
and target are in sync so but what
happens the changes are happening
between time t1 and t2 because this is
like a flowing river so data flow never
stops so what we do is so we take the
time t1 minus 5 minutes so we'll go back
to the time and then we run in real-time
CDC so using a stream so we're going to
have a five minutes overlap so but we
don't miss any data so that data will
apply all the duplicate data happens at
the target side because the data might
exist because up at five minutes and
then scanner will ignore it
so after catch up the real time so then
our a time three t3 both source and
target are
near real-time so that is very critical
for our business whatever happens change
is happening at the source databases in
the t-butyl mainframe are oracle the
applications are we using so the
customer is accessing data using zcp
apps using Google Apps so they should
get the Surreal data and a real-time so
so that I can't like a near real-time so
in our shop so when we did this from
source to target it takes 200 to 300
milliseconds so when you talk about this
you need to talk about the network speed
the unit is law a lot of cleaning
parameters sweetshop is different so but
that's what we achieved so that's that's
one of the major requirements for us so
here I'm going to talk about swipe out
spanner because we have many databases
so we have so many options
why clubs spammer so we need a
consistency of the invented data from
source and target and also so the
accessing data are supposed to be faster
so we have so many databases everything
a TSP sweet time so span them stays on
top of it so then when you look at our
options
so spanner fits our requirements and
also most importantly as a DBA
as a database person I but one of the
requirements is high availability and
disaster recovery by definition spanner
su can span multiple regions so that
will satisfy multi region so that
satisfies the disaster recovery in case
one reason goes down other two regions
can automatically pick over and also
high availability so one reason goes
down other reasons is always available
for us
but also transactions can be accessed
from anywhere so across the globe but
for us in the Macy's we see across the
United States
some can access from Chicago some can
access from not currently now some can
access from Texas and if I go to the
third option so that is the relation
system so this is these are so one of
the requirements so we are looking
forward so relation because all of those
databases all our transactional source
databases out of relational systems so
so it's easy to transform the
applications and systems from source to
target so if you have the similar or
same kind of support so this is full
fledge relation system spanner okay so
like I mentioned before so this is the
myriad real-time data responses and the
last ones are faster and then so so
greater shouting will happen in the
spanner so that's that also meets the
requirement so now so the last point is
need need for ability to scale the meet
spikes in demand so this is one of the
key requirements for a retail industry
because retail business is not same like
any other day if you compare it to Black
Friday and Cyber Monday those Peaks are
very high so spanner is easily scalable
horizontally scalable and so during the
peak time so that stop so ourselves our
capacity issues and also user experience
during all this time next so so this is
the architecture wise Y string so we
have been in application tools available
so in the market so Y string right so
stream has a highly available so
real-time replication system so I can
say near real-time replication but also
stream
has proven the low latency and to end
application so that takes milliseconds
to reach from source to the target like
I mentioned before so that is very
critical for our business I need for
enterprise great features like high
availability recoverability ability to
handle volumes and velocity so we talked
about high availability that is for
requirement for any tool or any process
we use and also ability to handle value
in velocity so this is like a critical
point for retail industry when you see
during holidays this is a very needed
point so because we need because of
violence go up our speed goes up a lot
of transaction goes up so stream is
supporting that and this requirements
also lead to the need for CDC solution
so we have application we have so many
ways but stream what's in the CDC so
that is the change data capture solution
so which is very proven technology
analysis fast as if you won't put a lot
of stress or resource constraints at the
source level and the next one is need
for ability to write multiple targets so
this is important too because if you're
publishing your data to the spanner and
then same date I may need to consume by
the pub so now city code so you don't
need to depending on the data to commit
on the spanner they write it to the pub
table from there go to decoding now the
stream can one app can run in multiple
targets
sometimes all these targets can use for
different different use cases but we can
achieve with one app from stream so
there's something I added advantage so
the final point compliment compute an
existing investment so what does that
mean
that means we already invested the money
on this Golden Gate
so the Golden Gate is already extracting
the data and then replicating two
different databases so there suddenly we
are invested the energy and money on it
so now stream has the capability to read
the Golden Gate ride files which so
which is which is complement existing
investments so what does that mean
so so here at Macy's so we are already
using an application to sue Golden Gate
so our little Golden Gate so which is
which is replicating data from the
source database to the target databases
from IBM mainframe to Target so stream
has a has a capability of reading
Golding it tried files and they
transform the data or replicate the data
into the DCP spanner pops up a decoy so
so that's that's our region so we just
achieve the process so without investing
another CDC process are like MQ kind of
process so so this dis complement the
existing investment now say efforts so
that helps us so that concludes my
presentation and so I know this is not
completed this is not complete picture
you may have some more questions if you
have any questions if you need to
understand more deep how we did it um
what we need to get it done so I'm happy
to answer those questions so thank you
and just hand it over to Alok Thank You
Neil thanks very much and particularly
you know I wanted to mention a couple of
points one was of course that during
peak period when you guys had the 7500
transactions per second the end-to-end
latency to keep the solution real-time
two to three hundred milliseconds as you
pointed out I think that was really
really really good for trying to
modernize and the other part of course
was leveraging the existing investment
and I was
the CTO for Golden Gate so I'm happy
that you were able to take a stream
which is sort of a next generation
platform and complement that with your
existing investment so with that I'm
going to get into the details of the
stream platform itself as you guys as
Neil pointed out there's multiple
solutions and stream enables at a broad
higher-level category there's cloud
adoption hybrid cloud data integration
and in-memory stream processing so let
me step into each one of these so so
stream is a next-generation platform
what you've seen here is a layout so on
the left side you have what I call your
on-premise systems these could be your
current systems your legacy systems and
they could also be your best of breed
applications that are running on some
other cloud and on the right hand side
are the newer endpoints so as you are
modernizing your own business as you're
introducing newer systems be they be you
know cloud-based relational database as
a service or no sequel systems or
storage systems or analytic systems
oftentimes you want to bridge this gap
and one of the key things is if you take
a look at trying to keep things
consistent and you know real-time
traditional technologies don't always
meet up to that to that goal and there's
several reasons I'm going to share okay
so the way to look at and interpret this
slide is going from the left to the
right
you need a next-generation modern
platform that allows you to deploy these
solutions and with that there are nine
different flavors I don't have the time
to go into each one today but I
certainly want to touch on a few of them
which are relevant to what Neil talked
about so the first one is cloud adoption
so these have to do with today you might
be deploying your existing database
systems on-premise and you want to
simply migrate to the cloud because you
want to take advantage of let's say data
base in a managed fashion to lower your
cost to make it a lot more manageable as
well as to achieve the economies of
scale from a computer
perspective a storage perspective so
that migration how do you do that
without interrupting your own business
operations and one of the very
interesting solutions here is to keep
your current application which is
running against our legacy system up and
running while you set up a parallel
system in the cloud and so long as
you're able to set that up
and keep the keep the two systems
synched up and concurrently running then
at some point you're able to transition
over your application onto the target
side so this is what I mean by the one
way migration more interestingly in Mesa
in the case of the use case that we just
heard about what they wanted to do was
take a legacy system in this case a
mainframe and take a lot of that data
and move that into a modern system like
cloud spanner so when you do that then
you need to be able to again replicate
that data so that's the replication
scenario and similarly there's also you
know requirements that come up as you're
trying to distribute your data so you
also saw that there was a needs
architecture slide there was a Google
pub/sub endpoint so that's a data
distribution use case as we try to
liberate our data as we try to modernize
our applications different parts of an
organization have their application
developer development teams their data
scientists their partners and they all
want to have access to this data
traditionally this has been problematic
because it is very expensive to collect
and ingest the real-time data that's
going against a very mission critical
system and that is one area where the
overall solution of doing a one-time
initial load followed by a change in a
capture allows you to effectively meet
that requirement
okay so just generalizing for I'm going
to go a little faster here a
generalization of the previous solution
category is the hybrid cloud data
integration so this has to do with the
fact that you may want to do not just a
one-way migration but have do a kind of
a synchronized migration where you know
you're running a system let's say system
a on-premise you're replicating it to
system B
then you do some testing on system be
possibly migrate a few users do a
reverse topology where the data is
coming back into the legacy system from
the cloud-based system and now you are
synchronizing these two and ultimately
at some point you're going to pull the
plug on one of them
real-time data integration big data
integration a lot of you are concerned
with doing data leak type of projects
when you're trying to take advantage of
cloud-based storage systems how do you
get data into those tiers so that's the
second category here and finally the
third one this is truly the the Gateway
towards digital transformation so how do
you deploy next-generation
advanced very thin apps so that they can
you know be deployed almost in a in a
microservices fashion just to give you
an example as you're moving the data if
you're trying to count up things to make
sure that operationally things are
adding up or if you want to alert on
them if things are not what you expect
so these are the what I call the
streaming applications that can be also
deployed to deliver to the business the
ability to monitor the operations very
closely as well as if you want to get
any insights into into the data
specifically for example you know let's
say if you're talking about order data
am i exceeding the number of orders
within a given time interval and should
someone be alerted in the journey off
now you can always do this by writing an
application on the target endpoint for
example in the google spanner but for
real time purposes oftentimes we've
found that people may want to do that in
the pipeline it's okay so that's this
third piece so our focus is really on
customers like Macy's and it's typically
the the global 1000 types of customers
typically these customers have a very
very strong requirement as far as scale
is concerned so their data volumes are
rather large and then they range anyway
from order of you know tens to 50s of
terabytes to to let's say as low as 50
gigabytes it doesn't have to be but
typically we see that the stream
solution is being adopted in these kinds
of environments and the one fundamental
thing that I really wanted to call out
was oftentimes as a reluctance to
modernize because there's an impact to
your actual application so let's say
your CRM application or your core
banking application retail application
inventory management application so how
do you then modernize that system by
making the actual technology that's
moving the data non-intrusive to the
functioning of that application that's
really where we focus on ok so why do
traditional data integration
technologies fall short here ok and
there's a there's a number of different
reasons so number one they often are
batch oriented and have a job mindset
which means that you know typically you
run some sort of an ETL job and then
that gets done and now you have taken
data that was different from last night
and now you move that into the target
system this is sort of you know can be
done lightly but that doesn't give you
real-time data so that's really one
fundamental challenge there number two
is just lack of support for data
streaming so if you wanted to give
real-time visibility and you're
operating off of a reporting system
that's reflecting data as of last find
then there is no possible way in which
you could do what Macy's was able to to
do which was to deliver consistency
across you know a system like spanner
number three scalability limits so you
want to have a system that can scale up
with your volumes so to that end stream
can is a distributed platform that can
scale horizontally number four and this
is a very innovative thing we have done
in a traditional data integration stack
by adding capabilities like data
validation
it's one thing that you move a finite
amount of data and you're done and now
you can do comparisons
it's another where the data flow will
never stop it's going to on an ongoing
basis keep moving and so how do you
ensure that the source and the target
systems are behaving as you expect them
to behave so that's this whole area of
data evaluation that we have added into
the platform and lastly if you wanted to
incorporate you know you know advanced
things like machine learning your own
models into the pipeline as those are
also interesting things that customers
want to do in traditional integration
stacks fail to accommodate for that
flexibility that the platform desires
so with in-stream what we've done is you
know we make the provisioning the
designing the deploying the monitoring
of these pipelines very very simple and
the way you do that is by using the flow
designer which allows you to connect to
a number of source systems and you can
design your data pipeline and then you
can deliver that data into a target
system so in this case what we talked
about was there would be a db2 or an
Oracle GoldenGate or an Oracle phase
system on the left side on the target
you would have a system like Google pops
up and top span and you could move the
data and along the way the interesting
thing is that you are able to do sequel
based processing on that data so you can
literally take a look at a record and
you're able to filter on that you could
have a very wide report format like with
four hundred fields and you could say I
want only 80 of these fields you could
transform that so if you had personally
identified five all records you could
mask those along the way you can do
aggregation by running sequel doing a
group by and condensing the record and
moving into a target system you can
enrich the data and you can also
correlate the data so these are the
capabilities I don't have the time today
to go deep dive into each one of these
but for those of you're interested
please reach out and we can certainly
help you with those with those use cases
a core differentiator is the ability
ability to do change data capture so
this
something that I highlighted earlier
that without causing disruption to the
mission critical application that is
running we want to be able to make sure
that the changes the inserts updates
deletes that are occurring in a
transactional fashion on your source
system can be captured and applied in a
transaction in consistent way onto the
target so this is the ability to change
data capture and stream supports a
number of different databases including
your popular relational databases either
running on premise or in the cloud ok so
as far as you know your overall journey
is concerned in terms of modernization
in terms of digital transformation in
terms of just getting to the cloud
specifically with Google what we've seen
is a number of the endpoints like
bigquery cloud pub/sub cloud sequel data
prod route storage and spanner stream is
being used to deliver data into these
endpoints and along the way you know you
could try it to preform at their data or
deliver it as is for the consumption
ultimately from these endpoints and so
we really simplify the cloud a little
bit okay so with that I'm going to give
you a two-minute demo of what we'll talk
about so let me go ahead and play that
so what you're seeing is the the
browser-based interface and there are
two separate apps here let me jump into
app one so this is one of the pipeline's
the top part of this is showing you that
we're doing an initial load from an
Oracle system and we are going to move
that into spanner in this case is the
line items table okay you can see that
there and remove about 100,000 records
here so let me go ahead and deploy this
app okay and once I deploy it there's a
preview capability available so you can
see the data online
that's ensure that the line item table
doesn't have any records in it so let's
go ahead and start the stream app and
you can see now that you know the data
is being moved you can see the records
if I go to the monitoring page I can see
that so far I moved about 86,000 and now
I'm in just about a hundred thousand
records and ultimately there you go I
have transferred a hundred thousand
records so if I come back and query you
can see that I have a hundred thousand
records in Spain or no okay so that was
the way in which you achieve the initial
load followed by the change in a capture
so in the KNG did a capture side you'll
notice it as a similar pipeline and now
in this case I'm doing this against the
orders table just to for the ease of use
once I start this application will use a
java application to go ahead and
generate some workloads so let's first
make sure that this table also has no
records okay let's start the application
generate some live data against this
table and then I'm going to go ahead and
query the orders table you can already
see that as soon as I started generating
the data I was able to see that in the
stream platform and then finally let's
query the span or system and you are
seeing that there's live records dinner
right so I just showed you both the
initial load and the change in a capture
and finally you can actually also move
to the monitoring page and there's all
kinds of boring details available here
as far as events in events out you can
see the hundred thousand records and you
can get a lot of the cluster related the
note related the appearance statistics
here okay so that was a very quick demo
so with that what I wanted to do was
just quickly ask Neil about maybe some
of the challenges and the lessons
learned as they delivered the solution
using the stream platform so Neil if you
could maybe help our audience with that
that would be terrific thank yellow yes
I definitely wants to share the lessons
learned here because this is going to be
any customer may have these kind of
questions or may see this problem so
some of the highlights here on the
lessons learn so importance of testing
and also validating all pieces we can
whatever we get whatever we see out of
the box or or the to provide
I see and then we need to be tested
thoroughly and make sure so it works
what it says is what you see right so so
that's a little critical point of
testing is very critical and some of the
data's because because I need to give an
example so you feel if your car so if
you are replicating data from TP to
mainframe infinity p2 data to the cloud
db2 mainframe most of the systems runs
on the character power set isn't it
silly so when you go to episode 8 - the
UTF Unicode so so then some of the
characters will act differently so this
is nobody's fault so but that's what it
is so we need to test that thorough so I
mean if you talk second one so need for
additional workarounds to take you flirt
whatever out spam so what does that mean
is okay right now so spanner but they
keep adding more features and more it's
coming Google is added and and as a
right now what I remember is a lack of
triggers unless there is no change data
capture so lack of triggers is we need
to find a way to do it and we may need
to have a other process to do the work
like trigger work but if you wrote it
but the spanner doesn't have a CDC what
are the changes or you already have in
the spanner you want to replicate the
data back to somewhere else so there is
no easy way so there's one of things we
need to keep that in mind and and if you
go to the next point so so the
architectural diagram are contextual
process so so we need because this is an
evolving process either stream or
spanner a GCP any product so we are able
to adopt and then evolve based on that
so so we're able to flex fully enough to
change those architecture then what we
are running on track
and the final is the Google cloud
provides a flexibility to grow and
quickly I want to keep pace with
changing dates so that is true statement
Google is working with us very closely
they are very helpful and so they did a
lot of improvements for us and they're
still doing it so so that flexibility
makes our project success so this is one
of the lessons learned and also and also
stream does very good job of working
with their vendors with their customers
and they make the quick changes so so
that that adaptability will help us the
digital transformation or the growth so
that's all I have for today
well water look great thank you so much
Dale and I really appreciate you taking
the time and just as far as you know a
joint working together as partners I
think we were able to work with the
product teams and with Neil's team so
for example when you saw maybe some of
the apparent shortcomings or maybe
things that are on the roadmap like like
off triggers we were able to you know
innovate their make sure that we were
able to take advantage of certain
commits timestamps on the span or table
populate those so that downstream
applications could take advantage of
that and then achieve what they were
hoping to achieve so we were able to
satisfy that that type of solution so
with that you know please feel free to
reach me directly if you are interested
in the technical details as well as
additional demos and also labs so you
can reach me to look at stream and then
I really enjoyed thank you neil again
and I really enjoy presenting to you
today and thank you very much for it